guys what is the definition oh no of
consent oh my gosh what is ai look and
how does fraud work how does it work uh
welcome to the training
trial of sam gorski jake did you fly
here to serve sam papers yeah i yeah
usually i'm at my home studio in texas
but this week i flew all the way to los
angeles all the way so that the trial of
sam could decide i could be a witness
against him yes you'll guys notice uh
jake and myself are sitting on opposite
sides of the room literally as far away
from each other as they can get yes yeah
because uh unfortunately after the video
last week uh
well let's just say the relationship has
been shaken up a little bit soured
soured
after i did what i did
you just
didn't get that consent that was so mean
can i just say was that mean
just real talk for a second we've gotten
a lot of uh
comments on the videos both on corridor
digital and on uh the crew channel
and uh we just thought it would be a
good opportunity to take time talk about
the video talk about the context talk
about kind of how things work when we
approach these videos and then also
maybe get into like
some of these other issues like what is
consent and what is a.i
staged and what is storytelling
what is not staged so i think the first
thing we should do is just kind of go
over like
how did we get here you know what
honestly i think we should have you
say it because in that video i'm not
gonna say the consent line i do i do a
lot of talking okay
the video is me talking a lot and so i
think jake you should
summarize in your words
what happened i mean dude like
i didn't see the final final video until
uh like right before it went live
and the day before
that is such a good video
oh my god like it's got such an
emotional like journey it's got you're
messing around with the tech like it's
it's it's
and i think that's
what
fooled people and and we didn't even
sometimes this happens
we'll tell a story and to us it's like
very obvious and apparent that like
certain portions of it are staged or
like there's a you know there's like a
underlying context to how we're going
into it tongue-in-cheek yeah and that's
because you know we we sometimes we have
these ideas like weeks in development
months in development sometimes some of
them do some of them are like years in
development
and and that was one of these ones we
had talked about this video
this couple weeks in development nico
did his and then timing-wise it worked
out great but we had already had this
established context of like okay we're
gonna do a voice ai video we talked
about using someone's voice in the
studio and we were like okay let's and
obviously we had talked about it being
me because i'm the brand guy and so the
context was like well if we can come so
the ultimate goal here is to come up
with a completely ai jake
i think yeah yeah eventually we want to
automate your brand yeah it's on the
list of big goals yeah to do so
so like with consent we've already seen
the earlier versions of that too where
you have the the mannequin with the
tablet yeah right now it started with
the green screen avatar that clint was
puppeting for us
[Laughter]
two years ago nico and i started filming
with this little startup down the street
this voice ai video yes so we've been
wanting to do it thing is we couldn't
find a good story for it it was like
okay what do you do with voice ai like
what's the story
and i think dean you found a great story
well yeah i think sam just saw that
there was a need you know there was
there was a demand one person in
particular had had a distinct need for
this voice ai and that's jake right well
like
let me look i think jake i think before
we even talk too much further i think
it's just important that you still
explain
what happened in forgetting the video
for a second yeah what happened in real
life so we left off with we've so we've
talked about this in fact even the
podcast two f podcasts ago yeah we
talked about this talk that we recap
this whole thing saying what we're doing
so so yeah so let me pick it up there uh
so so then
we're we're every week we have a meeting
about what videos are coming out that
week what videos are in production
what's sort of on the in in the queue
and then dean and sam are like all right
we're going to do this voice ai one and
sam was like well i got to keep little
parts of it a secret just for like
dramatic effect and stuff and i was like
okay so we had talked about it we had
talked about
you know the sort of like overall this
is what we're gonna
this is what we're gonna try to do
and then dean and sam went off and shot
it
and
i i asked you on like
a few days before i was like is
everything good you guys are good and
you guys are like yeah yeah we're good i
was like okay
don't worry about it and i didn't and a
lot of times people don't know this but
a lot of times we will hold off on
talking about stuff to like to each
other
until it's on camera just so that
there's more of a natural reaction to
things
and that is super important for like
establishing a genuine presence in in
the video so that they're truly
entertaining and that's one thing i knew
you guys were doing voice voice ai and i
kind of knew my voice is probably going
to be involved somehow i didn't know
exactly how i would say you knew
everything
but that you hadn't
given okay
we'll get there we'll get there okay
so we're gonna get there so then
so then
this and then you use the decoy which is
classic which is what i did with my
batman and superman videos which is i
had somebody else say something about
something that was happening oh that was
so critical so nico put out this oh nika
wants to have a
studio protocol meeting
which made everyone so like irritated
everyone's like this is stupid
like you're saying this is dude nick i
even heard that nick was like almost
stupid
[Laughter]
i was like what company culture are we
talking about it's just not a good
scooter even though four o'clock two on
like a thursday is not a good time for
that
yeah
so
nico presenting it is so critical
because if sam
everybody said this if sam had come up
and be like hey guys i got a video to
show you everybody yeah right yeah
you're right sam but nico coming up
everybody's like okay right he's
probably got something right nego often
brings you know kind of policy things to
the table yeah it made sense jake and
going into that meeting what was your
like feeling what was your expectation
like christian
and i were talking that morning and or
like maybe it was the day before and he
was like yeah nick wants to do this
thing at four tomorrow like a studio
protocol thing and i was like oh okay
and i actually had notes prepared
i had some things to say i had notes
prepared for like studio protocol and
like company culture stuff that i just
i've been like i've been like keeping
track of a few things that i have would
like to mention you know these dishes
are starting to pile up
um and so i thought i thought that that
was gonna be a genuine like protocol
meeting but then when we sat down and
then sam was messing around with the
video i was like okay um i i still
didn't know what it was about
um
uh but like obviously i was giving them
the benefit of the doubt uh and then as
soon as the video started playing
i knew exactly what had happened well
before that nico says so jake jake
prepared a video because he said that i
knew well you said it like oh
you're like what
you're like what excuse me
yeah but the thing is that was the plan
was we get you on the call we have you
speak out to everyone and once we make
sure everything's working we just mute
you
oh god so that worked brilliantly which
i was very proud of because i've been
doing the pranks around here lately and
it was funny to get pranked
um and and then this this stupid like
script that the ai wrote was so dumb um
and then yeah and then after i think you
cut most of this but like after
the actual video played yeah i i i
started just going along with it to see
who else we could fool yeah because i
knew that i knew what it was because you
didn't know the crime at the center i
didn't know the crime at the center
which we'll get to
um so then offense yeah and then and
then you were like wait but seriously i
need your consent and that but you
didn't really you know like technically
you did but you he had already
and the thing was is i didn't know what
i didn't know what a.i you had used and
so i i was actually like hmm
maybe i shouldn't consent to this
because i don't know what's going to
happen with my name and likeness but
then i i did read the terms of service
and
and it's totally fine like it's it's
just for yeah but that's funny because
that your your apprehension on like
how did you get this trained and who was
it trained with that
what that transformed into the overall
consent of like am i okay with having my
voice replicated in general right and
that's how it comes through in the video
which obviously is where and so just
people have context here like sam and i
are partners in in this business and
like it's
so anything that like
you know so so there's no pressure from
your nose yeah
yeah
it wasn't like that content right and we
also have a general policy which we
could have gone over if it was an actual
protocol meeting
yeah let's revisit our contracts please
which is if you if you are uncomfortable
with anything that we're going to put in
a video
it's your call you get to have it
removed yeah and we've always been like
that i don't know why i'm looking at
camera so much i guess i'm talking to
the viewer
yeah well a lot of people are
rightfully upset by this video so i mean
we are kind of talking portrayed i just
want to hit that point like know
that we never
put pressure on people to be like you
need to be in this video and you need to
give your consent like if i would have
been actually uncomfortable with that i
would have just been like yo no we can't
really you wouldn't have seen the video
it wouldn't have come out yeah no one
would have seen it no one would have
seen it but the funny thing is is that
so there's this question
that people were proposing and
discussing which is is this video staged
because that
fact seemed to be what
what all the morality hinged on which
was if this is for real this is really
bad yeah and if this is stage it's just
a tasteless narrative yeah and it still
makes me sick it still makes me icky but
the money
is is that
was this staged
no
it wasn't staged yeah i legitimately
you know
without your permission right here's the
service to make your ai voice i wonder
you were already okay yeah you're making
an ai voice for yourself i was like
there's i was already so that's another
huge point it's very muddy because
it's not like you stole his credit card
info or something it's like you did a
thing that you could have done without
his consent
but the hilarious part of it is that
just for this one service you needed to
manufacture his consent and we had
talked about that to each other yes you
you were we were talking about on the
podcast we had talked about it not on
camera as well and you were like yeah so
i have to do this thing where i give my
voice and i was like well that's crazy
like what's you know
and so i knew and we and then we also
said we should do a voice ai for me yes
and so like i had already
i already agreed with the premise yes
you know it's just funny yeah but the
thing is that like i i just it's
how unstaged it really was and like that
was the thing like i just didn't want to
respond to any of these comments because
i'm like
nothing i can say
technically
i can't just summarize this quickly just
saying don't worry guys it's all staged
because it's like right
it wasn't right guys huge thanks to
storyblocks for always sponsoring this
podcast um i wanted to do this
integration with nick because uh he
actually uses storyblocks oh yeah big
fan um so nick storyblocks claims that
they're the one stop shop for all your
stock asset needs would you say that
that's uh fair i think that's pretty
accurate man i mean whether it's uh you
know shots of
corporate millennials you know pointing
at white boards right or hikers going
through beautiful glaciers forests
you never quite know what you're going
to need literally you can build the
craziest stories would you say that they
have a virtually unlimited library of
high quality 4k b-roll images audio
stock assets such as motion graphics and
after effects templates and more
yes to all the above do you appreciate
that they have uh an unlimited
all-access plan where we can download as
much as we want however we want and use
it in whatever boy do i yeah no i'm all
royalty free we we have been
blessed with a corridor account right
and
like three of us
editors yeah we we tap that all the time
well what's funny is they were using
them before they sponsored them they
were yeah we were using them back when
they're called video blocks sorry story
box corporate
we won't show the logo
um
we've honestly been using them for a
long time and
stock footage is like the most useful
thing is any kind of filmmaker even if
you're just roughing stuff out like
dude in fact you know what
it's really funny
we went and saw this netflix preview
screen can't say what it is or who it is
they used story blocks did they shots of
l.a for their intros like so like even
at the top they're using story blocks to
like even just rough stuff out and like
give a really cinematic feeling for like
i don't know it was just so funny i'm
like oh yeah i use that i think that's
all you need to know right there like
that's that's a beautiful summary of how
we use it and why we use it so if you
guys are interested in being a serious
creator maybe you're a serious
professional creator already and you
just need that extra tool
storybox is what we use we highly
encourage it and if you're interested
head on over to storyblocks.com or cast
or just click the link in the
description below what was that nick
what was the url i believe it was
storyblocks.com
corridor cast there you go back on to
this uh
sam's trial oh yeah yeah
but it's deep it's like this is why we
have to have a whole podcast about it
everything here is kind of staged and
kind of not staged it's like
literally i think there's like an
overall context too and you guys being
really good friends and partners and
also us also knowing that we're
being working here
we're going to be in content
we're going to have we're going to be
the center of pranks content zany things
and of course we have the right to veto
them right if we want right i don't know
it's just like there's a lot of context
missing i think
reading the comments
what it's telling me is that this is a
really good video
i think you did a great job dean telling
the story honing in on the scariest part
of ai which is people taking your [ __ ]
and replicating it without your consent
yes and we focused on the most dramatic
aspect of all af for people and i think
it really struck a chord dude and i i
think this you know we've been doing all
these ai videos and this is something
i've really thought would be fun is like
to get into the morality of it because
it it's weird and like you know there's
this weird part at the end of the video
where everybody's
screaming at jake to give his kids to
this machine
this is the weird territory we're
starting to get into where it's like we
can make
completely convincing
uh
replicas of people's voices people's
faces
and without their consent and like
there's like i said
plenty of services where you don't even
need to have somebody say like oh yeah
i'm cool with this it's like you could
just
you know sam says in the video like we
do with mark hamill just grab a bunch of
his face and then you could throw his
face on somebody you know or with
other voice services
you can just
you know so there's so many there's so
many moral and like legal lines here
that are all converging which is why
it's so confusing for people and this
happens every time an impactful new
technology comes out um but like
you know we saw that one descript i
think it was maybe it was
a different one but they had taken
barack obama's voice and i think that's
reese feature yeah and the guy was able
to speak and then it sounded exactly
like him so with a guy like that with
barack obama like not only is he a
public figure but he's also a politician
so then like your your level of like
protection for your own name and
likeness
goes down in terms of like people's
ability to use clips of you to use your
voice for things because you're a public
representative of the people yeah and so
then there's another tier after that
which is like celebrities and stuff
people who are not elected but are still
known in the public culture and in the
public conscious and then there's people
like like me for example on the on the
show that we're putting it on
it's like
you know it's like people expect
me to be on in the videos sometimes like
my voice is in the videos my face is in
the videos like
and so
if it was a random person and you were
like random person's voice and and it's
a real person
took that and now we're exploiting it
for money
like that's a clear yeah that's not free
speech that's fraud right that's that's
just stealing someone's name and
likeness and also like it's blatantly
being used for like the goofiest end
game ever to make a
really
motivational team
and like
that needs to be taken into account too
i think yeah
there's something but people don't care
i want to talk about
like the ability to use it for nefarious
things but also that's important
um
but
yeah like
the
the context of of how it of how that
came about is like
it's everything and and obviously we
didn't show all the context because it's
not
as good of a story
yeah but the story was it's like
looking at it like this the way you told
the story was it was very truthful to
honestly how it went down yeah obviously
yeah there's no i wouldn't say there's
any lies no like the only like the only
thing that's obscured is really just
like the see the scene zero which is
jake and me saying hey yeah let's do an
ad version of your voice
you know
which happened multiple times and even
was recorded and uploaded to the
internet but the thing is is
you know like when it comes to the
morality part here it's like i when i
was asking for your consent by the way
like i was being legit like i was being
totally like obviously i could have done
it but the thing is i had to forge your
voice yeah to do it because sam is a
moral actor yes i will say though i
think there is a world where if we
weren't as story focused and we were
more afraid of maybe i don't know
pissing jake off right for real right we
could have just called jake and be like
hey can you just like consent to this
real fast for making this video right
like hey it's just pretend like you
don't know what's going on in the scene
we're gonna film in three days yeah like
i remember dean came over to the desk
and you just shot with sam and you're
like dude i found the story to this
video yeah like we just figured out we
have to get vocal consent i was like oh
that's great yeah so like
but like if there's any thought in my
mind that like oh jake's gonna [ __ ]
like come from texas and beat sam's ass
he probably wouldn't have done that
video no no no
i totally wouldn't have because that was
the thing like we were i was researching
like there's a wide variety of ways to
do this um and they all involve like you
know uploading clips of your voice and
doing all that stuff so i'd already
started collecting podcast stuff and i
have you know
for multiple people here and so
it just so happened that one of the
services that happened to be like that
perfect middle ground of ease of use and
quality
required
this one specific way to unlock the
voice right and that was like where the
whole idea for the story came from which
is like
other like there's tons of other ways
where it's like i didn't even have to do
that yeah like if i was just if i was
just downloading like the git or
whatever on running python on
one of these machines you also i don't
have to do that consider it legally in
the in the context like sam and i have
already agreed to use each other's name
and likeness for exploitive purposes
to the endeavor of the business yeah
like it that that whole like you need to
consent to this we need your line
is is is already superseded by the
contract that like sam and i have with
each other
in the business but i will say there are
still
real life stakes where sam is sitting
there and he's like
wait jake you're not giving me your
concern
to know that this was okay
[Laughter]
that's the scene that really miffed
people was everyone cheering consent and
i get why okay like now looking at it i
totally understand why why everyone's
triggered because the word consent has
baggage yeah there's the venn diagram
where you have yes you have the circle
of sexual assault and then the other
side of the venn diagram is like terms
and mindlessly scrolling through the
terms of service of the company and
hitting agree right and the word consent
overlaps just a little bit in the middle
right and that's
where most of this conversation
lies right
where it's like it's just the concept of
the word consent
in public discourse is generally
only used when it comes to sex
right you know and so like i dudes
or something like something
fortitude i needed over the weekend was
very very strong reading through the
comments dude i was like dude sam is
giving rape vibes to this whole video
and they're like i'm like frick that was
the weirdest part it was like like it's
obviously a tech experiment
yes there's some like controversial like
ai stuff going on and like identity
theft stuff going on yeah all for a
story but people are instantly going to
rape
and like whether they say rape but they
say like you know
consent is like like i'm getting like
this is not a good thing to like put out
for like male young males
we're not going to treat our audience
like children like okay like no way
we're not gonna sit down be like okay so
yeah consent
yeah let's talk about the new concept
yeah no it's like you should be able to
discern that this is yeah a completely
different side of the venn diagram
yeah yeah it's it's just yeah that was a
bit weird there's that whole thing and
then there's this whole other subject
which i think i i i was reawakened to
which is this concept of you know how
you are viewed so to speak because like
when we're filming these videos like
we're
you know we're just right here filming
videos with each other but then
they go through the editing process the
narrative becomes streamlined and it
gets sharper and then when it gets
released you know like it it's not like
people see just a bunch of real people
agreeing to do things it's like it
becomes this own like
narrative and we become characters
and so then suddenly like
the way people perceive these events
happening it's like the narrative
hones in on an emotional state or an
action and amplifies it you know for the
sake of storytelling but then
our decisions and actions and words
become larger than life and you know
that's
starts to
go into that tv show movie territory
because it's just the nature of the
medium
but at the same time it's kind of like
like my my mischievous or even maybe
villainous
like kind of element yes gets magnified
to the point where i suddenly become
you're the heel yeah this he'll work and
we saw this with the people video too
yeah that was the first time we had like
a huge like audience response to
something that we thought was absolutely
helpful because people will love it and
i think that's the time people get on
about our boy pete i think it's we you
know it was the heel thing too like
well yeah i think so yeah
like
in that context like people
was just having like a good time picking
on peter and peter was totally game for
it right but in editing that video i
just thought i'm sitting there like i'm
editing these videos i'm trying to have
a good time and it's i thought it was so
funny if i just cut out all the parts
where they're laughing
and i thought like if i if i like do a
hard zoom in on this like people will
understand that like it's a
like it's tongue-in-cheek like peter is
not peter is not if peter was
legitimately
feeling bullied by somebody at work
again we wouldn't put out the video it's
like
you guys are seeing something we're all
sitting there
dying laughing at it and it's the same
thing with this video
by the way like we all watch the videos
generally before they go out so like i'm
not sure you said you didn't watch this
one particularly but like it's general
thing that we all know what's going to
be released i saw it when you posted it
to you well it hadn't come out on the
website yet and you had also uploaded it
to youtube and so i watched it when it
was private scheduled yeah and then also
right after we shot that scene i was
telling jake like this is going to be so
funny and jake's like yes i also think
it's going to be funny yeah you know
well i think a large part of
the the outrage is also because people
like like you they love you as a
character i think i would heal in the
comments no no no no no not in this
video
like there's a huge part of the audience
that loves your like you know
independent spirit like you know that
texas vibe right and like that's a part
of your character yeah in real life and
on the show right so they felt pissed
when that got trampled on by real sam
like really
so that's my favorite part of the video
is when you're like come and take it it
sounds like but i already already
literally just took it
without asking
i know i walked myself into that one it
was funny
oh gosh back to the back to the chance
so so that's another thing like and we
we don't go into detail on that like
specific of hey if you're not
into
anything where you're appearing on
camera publicly in this setting
you just tell us and we don't talk about
that very often but that is that is like
a baseline
very well understood here and and so i
think for a lot of people who don't know
that and didn't see that then then yeah
it's like whoa like you guys did
you guys violated this guy you know but
i uploaded this video right and uploaded
this video but without that context like
it is hard to understand which is why we
wanted to have a podcast about it so
that people
who are interested can can hear that
side of it yeah i think there's a lot of
projection going on but also most people
i don't think people are wrong when i'm
reading these comments it's like we
can't dismiss them because like
obviously
we had that effect on people right the
choices we made
making this video had a overall negative
effect yeah but it's it's this it's so
what do we take from that well what i
seriously still take from it though it's
the like it's this like
it's this prism of like emotion where
like
they're reacting
like is there
you know it's like do they watch game of
thrones you know and they're like oh i
hate that lannister you know or
something like that and it's like well
you know it's like the effect of like
sometimes hating the actor yeah when
it's like no this was just lines you
know what i'm saying and there's like
this weird blend going on there where
it's like they they hate me and they
think i'm
non-consensually
doing things
you know what i'm saying but but the
thing is is that like the
is that hate and like they think
the hate and anger is personally
directed at me
but
like
it's really directed at the concept of
the narrative
rather
than
me personally but because it's youtube
it blends oh yeah right and so it's like
it's this weird it's it's really hard
for me
this is i generally try not to read
comments i've i've
this is not the first time this has
happened
you know like when i read comments like
this i'm like i kind of go like oh this
hurts and then i think about it more and
more like how do i get over this i'm
like oh yeah
become that
character become
this like creepy
like villain that's gonna just like make
fun and jack up everything people like
and try but try to make a great story
out of it you know like you try and keep
it and so it's like it's really hard to
resist that temptation to just like
embody that further you made me like
this it's like i'm like yeah here we go
how else am i gonna violate
you know like
i'm serious like it's really weird
sometimes the only way
like if you were to apologize then
people think oh that was all real and
sam actually did something wrong rather
than what it actually was was we're just
having fun and
you know
but if you are to lean even harder into
the character people start to understand
like oh this is a character like i'm not
watching sam like like a hundred percent
real sam i'm watching like heightened i
know we almost need to have a follow-up
video where it's like i stole everyone's
voice yeah
and i'm like
clips and they're like was that me i'm
like
it's mine
i own you
you know it's like people will watch it
and they go like oh okay i get it like i
get it yeah yeah i don't know
i think it's literally the term consent
triggers a lot of people especially when
a whole group of people i didn't even
think about that because my lawyer brain
is like
like when when i hear the word
molested in like a context that is other
than with a child you know yeah like i
think of it in the true sense of the
word which is the legal sense of the
word which is to like manipulate and and
and change something like without you
know
with that with malice usually right um
and and so that's another thing and then
like the whole fraud thing of like you
defrauded jake like so just let's just i
just wanted to mention this
fraud is the material misrepresentation
of a fat of a fact it's the
misrepresentation of a material fact
which causes another person to act in
their detriment
and so first of all if if it's
a material misrepresentation if i know
about it
it's not it's not a misrepresentation
because i know the truth
right and then obviously there's two the
second part of that is it has to cause
me to act in my detriment nothing about
what you did in fact everything about
what you did only benefits me because
i'm part of this company
yeah you know yeah so so like it's that
it cannot by definition be fraud even
though without the context it's like you
could see it as that but i mean yeah
well that's the fun actually moving to
silicon valley
i realized what was happening when he
said he was moving to california because
i know he hates everything about l.a
jordan had like out of everyone jordan
coleman had like almost no idea what was
going on because she's like running
around doing a million productions yeah
and it's like [ __ ] i gotta do this
meeting well because the funny jake's
gonna tell us the big announcement yeah
yeah yeah all the funny things dude i'm
moving to california i was pretty like
since you weren't in the studio last
week too it's like i was
way too vocal about what i was doing for
like it to really fool anyone watching
yeah like as everyone had heard me say
ai always working on an ai voice thing
blah blah and so it's pretty common
knowledge that once it started playing
and this was it was that goofy that was
like oh this this is it this is the ai
voice thing he was working on but you
can see the different levels of of how
tuned into that people were yeah with
with jordan and uh who else uh
who else was oh griffin
yeah cause they're they're like the
furthest removed from the process that
you two were doing yeah um like
physically
they're just
um so that was yeah um a lot going on
there but illegal okay so legal
ramifications i think that's this is
this this is a multifaceted subject
which is
really funny uh um let's start with the
like the easiest thing which is yes i
did get banned from using their service
yeah okay um i was i was i kind of knew
this was gonna happen because we were
literally doing a video showing how
we're we're subverting it right breaking
obviously and like their ceo emailed us
and he said hey just heads up uh since
you publicly slashed flagrantly
violated
you know terminated your account
and but they did he was he was he wasn't
he was very cordial about it he was like
just saying
you know you violated the terms of
service but also just recognizing
what you ended what you did wasn't
unethical
yeah you know because
there was all this context there and he
was like
he was pretty nice about it and i
responded and i said yep
not surprised like i was waiting for i
was literally
waiting for an email from you guys i
knew this was somehow gonna land on your
doorstep i knew i was gonna get banned
but you know here we are but great work
guys you have a great product and great
service wish you all the best so it
points out a couple things like
had it happened in the exact
manner that was sort of portrayed for
dramatic effect in the video where i was
totally unaware
sam was my boss
like he was gonna then use it and take
it and do whatever he wants with it
like obviously that's unethical
obviously obviously this is that wasn't
the context and we would never do
something like that if that was the
context yeah
like and that's the bottom line there
was a very large number of comments
saying that i
would be going to prison
[Laughter]
to brazil
it's like if i were jake i'd be pressing
charges right now yeah no this is legit
illegal please i'm begging of you guys
to have jake make some sort of public
statement and pull back the curtain at
least on twitter that's what we're doing
now we're doing it right now this is
awful disgusting and wrong
i know you meant it in good fun but
you've given people the wrong idea
which is valid that that little point
possibly
uh peer pressured someone and broke in
the terms of service this is wrong and i
refuse to support any company performing
such disgusting acts right that's a real
comment and that's is that that's
quarter digital's not descript right
that's the ceo
there's this one i'd prob punch the guy
who used my voice like that i probably
uh i know i got it i i i haven't gotten
any like direct threats it's all in the
comments which is good i mean what was
that email you were talking about there
was one email from a someone who claimed
to be a solicitor on australia's or
queensland supreme court something like
that
and he was just outlining you know that
what we did was fraud and i could be
sentenced to four to ten years of jail
or whatever in australia i believe he
said this video should have been left on
the cutting room floor yeah
so again like obviously
you know considered without any context
whatsoever
and sort of with this overarching
perception of like
my name and likeness isn't already on
the channel
i'm a random person
the consent thing and how it kind of you
know it's going towards like
very personal things
um
yeah i get some of the some of the
outrage but it it it's because it was
it's because it was designed to tell a
good story and it does tell a good story
and that's why i think it's a great
video would you okay i'm just saying
like realistically here it's like
let's let's just talk through this
let's say
i'm going to prison
for using an ai voice okay
what do i actually have to do
to
to land in prison in the first place
because
i i'm not currently i'm not going to
prison you can go to prison for fraud
yes it could be fraud it would have to
be like egregious fraud
to the point where you know they'd be
likely to sentence you for more than one
year
yeah and
yeah it and again it you have to
materially misrepresent a fact
such that the other person
is harmed by it whether it's physical
emotional financial harm mostly
financial harm is the most is the
easiest way to summarize it
i don't know if you guys have seen this
there's actually
an example of this case uh there was
somebody shared it in our uh company
chat but
there's a mother of a cheerleader oh yes
uh who was accused by another mother
of
making a deep fake video of the other
mother's daughter
vaping
and so essentially this this mom is
accused of like creating all these deep
fake videos of these kids doing awful
things because
i don't know she wanted to
catapult the other cheerleaders to make
her daughter who's also a cheerleader
like more successful or she just
like trying to like say oh my daughter
doesn't vape it was a deep fake well
she's trying to make everyone else look
bad so her daughter succeeds exactly
yeah and so well that was the that was
the argument and i saw i went uh because
recently the charges got dropped because
you watch the video and it's like this
girl this high school girl is obviously
just vaping like it's just obviously a
video of her vaping and then they cut to
the interview with the daughter that the
news did and she's like oh yeah it's
crazy they can like fake these videos
now
obviously crazy and this but this
mother who was accused got charged like
i think there was a trial and everything
in her life and her
public image was like ruined by this
because i went back and and looked
originally when the
when it was looked like she had actually
done it like 10 months ago or something
and all the comments were about how this
woman is an awful person so you're
saying the raw like the final
video
that was this video of this girl vaping
yeah
did that in any way look like a deep
face no it just it's it looks so and
also high schoolers like what high
school doesn't vape it's like right it
just looks like such a normal video of a
girl vaping yeah but
and obviously it shows what a lack of
understanding people have of this
ai deep learning stuff yeah that this
probably like
60 people think this 60 year old woman
knows how to make a deep fake
she took nico a perfect like like a
perfect defense which took me like a
year to learn how to do obscuring her
face nico like a professional smoke too
yeah yeah i mean dude
well so that's important
i think it's important to like bring
that up because a lot of times
you know
average viewer
not spending their time
harnessing ai technology for creative
purposes
not
taking time to understand the nuances of
visual effects and how different
techniques work and need to be applied
all of that stuff
especially when you get into like the my
child zone and it's like high school
especially with how paranoid people are
of like
you know anything that can be bad for
the kids like
yeah that i can see how people would
flip out about it but it also does
highlight and i think this video
highlights it as well it's like i don't
know how well
people grasp this stuff yet yeah because
it's not really publicly talked about
and and any time it is brought up you
know there was the whole thing two years
ago when it started to become like
when we started to see deep fake videos
more often
all you could read about was just fear
mongering yeah when it came to like
traditional articles and information
sources about the topic it was just like
what's a deep fake it's when somebody
steals your voice and you're or it's
when somebody steals your face and puts
it on somebody else and they can make
you say and do whatever you want
whatever they do i think they they think
somebody just steals your face and they
can like push a button and make you say
anything right and i don't think it's
interesting like there's a lot of
emotion around this word consent but
there's also a lot of emotion around
ai
yeah your likeness stuff because people
are really
worried about this stuff and rightfully
i think it's again like another
interesting thing to explore with this
video
uh is how scary it's getting but it's
still
you know if you were to actually
pressure test this jake voice
it doesn't you know there's no
tonality to it it's just very monotone
very low like you can get we can get
away with some stuff but like we there's
a brand integration in the youtube
version of the video yeah and we stuck
we snuck in some
it was about six or seven lines that i
didn't say
but in like one of the top comments
was like oh the they put it in the
you know maybe i did say those and you
guys just typed them in i don't know
what you did for that so we literally
just took your whole clip that you made
for storyblocks
and i used dscript to transcribe it yeah
and then i just copy pasted the text
back into the ai voice yeah yeah
this it took like no effort so yeah i
mean give it a couple of years it'll
sound better i'm sure it'll sound better
i mean yeah like i i don't want to like
excuse it because of like the quality
too much
i mean it was pretty good it's a good
voice but that's why we did a
presentation that's why we did like a
boring corporate presentation because
the tone of voice like naturally fit
that kind of
like speech right you know like we
because we sat there messing with it
going
uh wait should we have like him leave
voice memos or something for say it's
like nah this just isn't working like
jake doesn't like with this voice like
jake never talks to anyone like this
this has to be just him
saying stuff right to no one because if
i recorded it to no one yeah if you
recorded it to no one because that's the
like yeah and so that's this is this is
the big issue still with like all this
all this stuff is that it's it's very
limited with its use so yeah i do want
to talk about let's go down this this
rabbit hole for a little bit because
right now
it is fairly limited with its use but in
like five years
it's not going to be as limited as it is
right now and publicly available stuff
is limited private companies
currently are doing it in amazing levels
yes
featured stuff
reese feature is just knocking it
blowing out of the water right now like
yeah they've tons of videos online
that'll scare the pants off and like
uh or
lighten the pants off you
because it's pretty cool too race
feature was used on uh the book of boba
fett for the new uh luke skywalker and
that's also the pinnacle of deep fakes
so
if people have seen that show
and have seen luke in that show that is
like the pinnacle i think of what you
can do right now with a
ai generated face an ai generated voice
which is
you know it's it's very convincing in a
curated context and i'm not trying to
argue that because it's not great
doesn't mean we shouldn't
be having conversations about this and
the implications but
i do think there's a lot of still a lot
of emotion around right the topic that
is oh yeah that people are treating it
like it's already out of control like
it's already yes you know and i think
that was a very um
positive thing when we did that video
about the andrew garfield leaked clip
because
now something comes out
and people just immediately say oh it's
defect you know deep fake and
i think like you're saying jake in five
years it
very well could be the case that that's
you know i've seen a lot of stuff
it could be not to get to
you know
current events with this but like a lot
of people sharing videos of putin that
are like pretty obviously just like
press conferences or something and
they're like look it's deep faked or and
i'm like there was one that was like on
a green screen and there was like
artifacting so everyone thought it was
totally fake yeah but even still it's
like what does it matter if it's fake or
not yeah like i don't get it like why is
it i mean that's that's the thing too
just backing up going like all right
this this putin press conference like
let's say it's fake
meaningless well it means no effect on
any news or public discourse
because there's still like people still
are and this will always be the case but
every one of us every one of all four of
us everyone else
we are reliant on outside sources for
information yeah and when there is a
threat to the truth of that information
it throws your world upside down because
you're like wait how do i know what's
real anymore
i think with putin it's more the idea
that oh they have the tech to fake this
and we're catching it like is this tech
out there already so what else are they
baking yeah it's it's not like oh
they're faking putin because you're
right like who why you know yeah because
they they could immediately just come
out and say this is fake and then i
guess
to your point jake like in the future it
gets to this point where something comes
out
people say it's a deep fake people say
no it wasn't a deep fake and then it's
we're just talking about like is any of
this real
but i think that's honestly just a
larger
[Music]
topic for the culture you know like with
the whole fake news thing
like
media being so there'd be so much media
that people can't even begin to consume
all of it it's just we're getting to
this point where
the internet might not be the most
reliable
source of information right you know
like you have to look we just go outside
and look at the real world yeah and
right all of us
are at risk of what we showed in that
video just by being on this podcast here
or having any sort of internet presence
soon you're not going to need probably
as much data to do this right
like i'm guessing the mount is
technically the so the lyrebird uh
algorithm that this voice is based on so
like that came up like three years ago
and what made it really special was you
could give it like
one like one to three minutes of audio
and it could basically recreate the
voice
like right now like they found they've
opted you know the reason i submitted
right now their minimum is like
10 15 minutes now i think that's to
really round it up but like yeah you can
do it with almost nothing yeah um
you know like i was thinking a little
bit like about that voice id process
that i had to go through
um because uh
you know people were like oh you're i
mean i did show how you could break the
rules yeah fine
it requires a lot of stuff
that being said
um i also was messaged over the weekend
by a viewer of ours
and that this viewer of ours
was like hey what's up and i i missed
one of his messages from like a week ago
and the message from a week ago was him
outlining basically everything i did
and saying that he had done it and he
showed me what he'd done with it and he
did it to someone else at our studio oh
[ __ ] and he even put that onto a video
and had the mouth move
uh yeah it's he did the whole thing and
so before the video even came out so
this is before the video came out and i
didn't i just you know it was it was in
my you know general messages on
instagram so i didn't get a notification
i i was just curious this weekend like
am i am i getting like crazy messages
right now so i check it and there's just
this one guy who
had done it i'm not going to name him
specifically but um who do you fake red
yeah it was wren
[Laughter]
i guess i don't want to name him
specifically he's because
he would he will he'll probably get
banned from the service uh if i do it
but uh basically um
the way he broke the voice id
was
the way you would actually do it if you
are
more determined and more skilled than i
am
the way he broke the voice id is by
taking the data set
he submitted to dscript
and then
running his own
ai voice offline model on his own
computer like with actual script like
you know like the way nico does it with
actual like python script and stuff on
just like a really
crappy ai voice model
and then just typed it in
and then uploaded that well we even
threw out that idea for a little bit of
doing that exactly we we that was that
was part part of that discussion is make
a let's make a crappy a1 ai one first
and then see if that works
um but
i think it really just comes down to
this idea which is like is it easy to do
that regardless of which methods like no
actually it's not easy like it takes a
lot of determination and work to do it's
not it's not
accessible to everyone you know it
requires a specific skill set and like
the right tools
and a certain amount of hours and energy
and effort to do it so it's not like
anyone can just hop down and do it still
that being said
like do they need better verification
yeah they should look at it they should
refinance
brought that up and said hey maybe
you've maybe you pointed you pointed out
some things that are
good for people to understand
completely it's like this this video was
valuable for
that reason mostly i think it's like it
shows people how easy it is to actually
do this and it's like those white hat
hackers or whatever who are hired by
corporations like hey can you hack into
our site and like tell us where we need
to strengthen it's like
okay we're all scared of ai taking over
our lives and being replicated and made
to say random crap you know do random
crap right so like isn't it in our
benefit if we're trying to break these
early versions and like yeah absolutely
it is especially when it's not like any
it's low stakes you know
it's for fun
yeah yeah i mean like i think in the
future if you know once the models start
getting actually better if you're going
to offer service that allows anyone in
the public to
kind of perform tasks like this they'll
require a deeper level of verification
and i honestly think
at that point you know
really the easiest way to do it is just
like do driver's license
yeah human verification it's like that
it's like it's less about like who you
know at that point it's
what it's not about verifying the data
set so much it's just making sure
that you really know who is doing it
and making sure that if something comes
out where it's like oh there's a crazy
model of this person's voice the people
at that company can just check their
records and go is anyone messing with
this right now and they're like oh
we we like we actually know the person
who's doing it so that way there's like
it's less about faking someone's voice
at that point but making sure that
someone is responsible if they do and
that already exists like uh d speech
what's it called script dscript could
literally probably go back and listen to
the voice sample you submitted and when
they do they'll be like this is the
jankiest [ __ ] i've ever heard in my life
the ceo posted him on the video and he
was like yeah so we looked through the
account we saw oh yeah he did like four
attempts to try and break
there's there's four voice ids uploaded
then the first three failed
and the first one was me just going like
uh i'm jake watson
and i'm like okay that didn't work okay
so then i like tried another one and
then uh this the third one was uh
me holding the microphone to the speaker
you know and just like and that didn't
that failed
because uh i think there there are
algorithms right now that can sense
whether you're
yeah it's actually someone speaking into
a microphone versus pre-recorded voice
and then the final one i did was i just
rerouted the desktop audio into my as my
mic
and that is what worked which again that
that takes a certain understanding of a
lot of different moving parts with
technology to be able to do it i mean i
just did i obviously just explained it
all but you know it's like what are you
gonna do it's like there's like two you
can make things
you'll be able to fake your teacher
giving a presentation now like basically
there's two things there's two cameras i
mean i think we do need to be
legitimately aware
about how
this technology can be misused and
and that's like anything it's like we
got to be aware about that with cars we
got to be aware about that with guns we
got to be aware about that with food
like
everything um
and if we're not then that's just
ignorance right but like
part one is hey let's make
let's make access to
you know verification and consent more
stringent
but then also there's got to be some way
where we can start to use ai to detect
ai exactly
i think that'll get very very much built
out i think something will happen
where
something genuinely like a lot of people
are genuinely fooled by something and
something bad happens
and then we'll have like uh some kind of
coordinated response yeah i mean there's
already companies that are like
basically cyber security companies that
are working on this right now like right
three years ago
was it three about three years
there was even a guy talking about his
startup that is all about verifying fake
videos you know deep figs fake videos
vfx like it runs it through an algorithm
right and it's able to apparently
identify that
and his whole thing was it was
meant for like war-torn countries like
what we're seeing right now like being
able to verify are these things real you
know so on that note we had a bunch of
people not a bunch of people but we had
a certain amount of people
it was
it was like a you know a handful or two
notice enough
of people emailing us
asking us to do deep fakes of putin
telling his troops to stand down and
to me
that's just
like it's such an egregious like
violation of of
everything like
one it's one thing to hey let's make a
deep fake let's take a
voice ai of jake and then let's
make it hilarious it's probably like
some sort of act of war it's everything
on both sides man it's like how dare you
and it's like also by the way everyone's
also like hey can you do this without
this guy's consent oh and also siri turn
off the lights
yeah you know oh that's a funny one also
like like alexa turn off the lights it's
like you are
you have to turn into an ai
you know
um so yeah that that like i just think
i'd encourage people to not live in the
twitter verse you know like realize like
hey these things do have real world
implications
and
saying that you can
schlep off the
means because of the ends you know
well you know i want this to happen so
you guys should do this and anything
that you need to do to get there well it
doesn't matter if it's a complete
violation in another context it's like
no you you can't you can't do that and
even if we could
that those videos would never get in
front of putin's troops i'm sorry to say
they are so
insulated in their own propaganda and
cut off from the rest of the western
media whatever yeah they would they were
just they never see the videos you don't
you don't use you're like talking about
unplugging their whole internet right
exactly and it would be a great excuse
for putin to be like oh look western
media definitely
fake what i'm saying right you know that
would escalate things so much yeah just
basically doing doing what they're
already doing to their own people
be so unconscionably irresponsible to
just like casually hey let's just do
this thing to influence a war
people's lives yeah people may die from
this but like you know what
yeah it's like something come on evil
right i mean like in my imagination i'm
just like oh i deep fake putin and all
the troops went home that's like a nice
thought right like yeah
like it's like a bad movie script
if we can download this into the
mainframe all the russian soldiers will
see it but even
with i gotta get to the bottom of this
like let's talk about boba fett for a
second and even with the most gladly
even with the best guys in the industry
working on this like right
and spending just their time on this one
environment this one character
you're talking to luke yeah right now
okay yeah that's the result
and and
you know
it's like
obviously if the technology keeps
evolving and it keeps becoming
accessible then you know is there a
universe that we live in years from now
where somebody could do the teenager
vaping thing
i guess i guess maybe there's a reality
that that exists but like
but we're already all plugged into vr
under the metaverse anyway yeah it's
just like you have to consider also live
action running alongside of that you
know i saw his virtual avatar
expose himself
right and he needs to go to prison i
heard you're not allowed i heard there's
uh space parameters now no there are
because groping was apparently a huge
problem in the metaverse
in the alpha people groping each other
no honestly
so funny now they're putting in like
hula hoops around people of like you
can't go near like involvement
with the people that
initially like caused that headline she
works for like another freaking vr oh
yeah yeah
yeah
she yeah she's just like i was
roped in the maid of hers and then she's
like
and then she goes working to work at her
own vr studio it's just her and her
friend like yeah
yeah no no it's like
so deep utilize cultures general
awareness and like yo people have to
worry more about headlines than d fakes
still
yeah honestly they definitely cause like
the yeah i feel like the
gbt3
like the articles it generates is so
much more convincing than the voices
that ai can create or the faces like the
articles that you pump out of those
they're like those like real articles
yeah because most articles are all they
are
by the way that is at a casual level
there are literally applications
they're paid services and you're like i
want to write an article about this
thing and you type in three bullet
points and then you click a button and
you're done yeah yeah like it skims
wikipedia and like fills it out yeah it
does that all like they do it for blog
posts too it's like you want to keep up
the blog but hate writing yeah and
they're like okay what's your blog about
this any any other facts then you throw
in your facts and then go like here's a
blog you're like cool you post it and
you're like that happened with the
motion capture suit article i remember
yeah yeah yeah there was this and it
still gets it i every i have a i have a
scraper on google that like scrapes for
quarter digital
and
and it kept we they kept using our name
in that article or the ai did
and they kept reposting it
but there was an article that was about
uh trying to trying to pump up it was
like one of those penny stocking
articles where somebody's trying to pump
up like a penny stock and like so
they're like oh guys this is the new
thing like mission co motion capture
suits you know they're going to be a big
deal so like invest now
and
and then i i didn't really read it i
like skimmed it and i was like oh yeah
look at that that's funny and i sent it
to sam and the crew
and sam was like oh this is an ai
article
you're like oh yeah
because all i i didn't send it like oh
my god look at this i said i all i did
was saw it was was the oh this is
somebody doing an economic analysis and
our name is mentioned because of motion
capture suits
yeah um but then they started talking
about bow hunting goats
what does that mean oh man it's crazy
man
it's
well
we learned a lot from this video i think
everyone learned a lot the same thing
happened with boss town dynamics yeah
when we did when we did the second boss
town
yeah i mean just trying that one that
one is still good egregious though for
people who fell for that because it's
like there's literally this robot like
saves his dog at the end of the video i
know but people were cutting that see
again it's all about context they're
cutting they're cutting out the
beginning they were cutting straight
into the thing where i'm handed the or i
hand clipped the gun right and then
start shooting the targets and then they
cut a few scenes and then they cut all
that other stuff out right i mean the
vfx are dang good the fact that you guys
used real muzzles and real like bullets
hitting stuff right because you were
actually to gun range yeah it makes it
like that extra level of convincing if
those were pp muzzle flashes or even
like even comp down the best muzzle
flashes it would not look there's just
something like so real about it right
especially when you view it on a phone
right and you don't have the console
yeah this is blowing my mind right now
right like going to an actual firing
range like actually shooting the crap
and stuff and you're like
those are good effects like yeah
it's
the best good ones you can buy yeah well
ren's been messing around with this uh
phone software i think it's called buy
play or buy plate or something
where it uses the lidar and the iphone
13 to track
uh the environment and basically kicks
out a cinema 4d
like project with a tracked camera to
your phone
so you can literally just film and then
just throw it in and you got the whole
scene like tracked ready to go right and
that's and that's wild so that with um
all of the new
like ai rotoscoping tools i feel like
the next boss town video you could just
freaking do it in like a weekend you
know because all of the things that were
tough back then are now like they're
getting getting easier ai tools
speaking of ai yeah sorry that was a
good segue yeah into uh
there's ai tools yeah ai influencers
actually happening yes
it's actually begun
the ai influencer the a.i influencer
it's
well it all starts with gpt3
we're going to take a script to the
brain it's going to output a prompt for
us that has everything from where the
social media post is happening a
location what's the overall mood what
dialogue is happening are there any
dance moves that are happening
and then also last but not least
what's the camera angle are we are we
selfie first person blah blah blah and
so i've got a pretty good prompt going
that's outputting pretty consistent
and zany results
uh and so we take that script that it
outputs and we feed that into unreal
where it parses it
and then
dynamically
sets the scene
to whatever we give it
um it's pretty cool
and yeah so it's like we have the
skeleton working right now so brad
there's a guy named brad he's peter's
buddy he's helping him on a game
and brad is a professional unreal engine
specialist
blueprint specialist or something i
don't know what you want to call him
anyway he knows unreal uh so he's
helping with some of the top level stuff
because he knows it better he knows the
program better than peter and myself
he's doing that
i'm doing character face animation stuff
lip sync blah blah blah
and
it's going we're gonna do it and the the
goal the goal what is the goal the goal
originally was a one button
influencer post thing you press
that's going to be a little harder and
that might go
that's down the line if we continue
working on it because it's the hardest
part right
uh but right now we can do it in like
batches basically that's how we'll
probably do it where we give it like 10
scripts
and it outputs that and then we would
upload those by hand i mean still if
you're not
i feel like it fulfills the idea as long
as you're putting zero creative input in
it's like you generate it
yes you throw it in
all we're doing is vetoing it when it
talks about heinous stuff yeah exactly
we do that yeah obviously there's a
finite like amount of things that it can
perform obviously like the dialogue is
infinite there's no limit on that
but obviously like environments dance
moves animations etc like we have to do
that currently there's not an ai that
can like animate the character
procedurally so to speak
so uh
yeah but this the script is always
procedural
the camera is always procedural like
where it is in the environment what you
know it's doing is procedural there's
randomness like it's there
it's designed so that there will never
be the same shot twice and ideally
there's never even the same like line of
dialogue twice
so it could go on forever
i feel like in order to really really be
an ai influencer though you need to have
procedural procedural
uh
gaffs
like maybe just slip in a little flat
earth line you know yeah you need to
have controversy in there man
a real influencer i tried that out
people love controversy it's really easy
to do that actually because you you
basically just tell it to talk about
deep subjects
and it will randomly select a deep
subject and weigh in on it
wow
like you can just be like wow
i i typed near-death experiences you
know as like a subject matter like topic
and it was like yeah
i think i had a near-death experience
this morning and i saw the light and i
walked towards it have any of you guys
had any experiences you know like it'll
go off on these wacky tangents like that
so we can have it talk about anything
and i think the fun thing is is like
right now so we're like prepping it to
basically do like batches because
that's just the best way it happens so
like
we'll have like 10 scripts at a time run
it'll just we feed it the script
obviously we have to plug in the voice
outside of unreal but
regardless you'll be able to hit play
and it will procedurally
do those scripts
and uh since it's all continuous like we
have this hilarious system where there's
like this thing called physical
animation which is like half ik where
let's say you're dancing in an area and
instead of your arm clipping through the
wall it'll like properly like bounce off
of stuff so it'll be like making this
mess basically as it goes through its
like house
and like later down like as we go deeper
into it we'll be able to see in the
background like previous locations that
are like what happened
and um
and then the one the one thing to think
about here is continuity
so let's say the character explores a
cave and finds an old treasure map and
it's very mysterious
um
what we do between batches is we
basically have recaps that get fed back
into the prompt this has to kind of be
done by hand still because
of the weird formatting but basically
all we do is write like uh like a three
or four sentence recap of what the first
batch was and it becomes canon and then
suddenly the next batch
has the potential to like
where it left off earlier wow which
that's the real fun in my opinion
because you start to kind of develop
this like long-running story now
and then that's where my heart's at
which is is like i want like post 40 to
like reference something like in post
11. yeah and you're like what
so you guys remember how i was working
on this chicken coop all right so we got
the chickens the other day uh
yeah so the way i think it's also going
to be structured here too i'm just going
all out uh uh so dynamically switching
locations is
something that's a little difficult so
the way we're actually going to do it is
we're going to basically design like a
kind of like an open world map
and that's where everything happens
so it's all centered around like a
virtual influencer house yeah right and
and that's like the main area building
yeah yeah
but then around it are going to be these
sub locations where we can have stuff
happen and that's how we are able to
basically get this streamlined and have
it function
effectively
um but that's what makes the batches
cool is because now they're all in the
same spot so like we go to the kitchen
we're outside in the front yard doing a
story and we come back to the living
room we see the kitchen in the
background it's like whoa it's like
we see
yeah evidence of the previous stories
happening but just know like this isn't
this isn't going to appear
as a real life
person in a real life environment this
is obviously all being designed in a
video game engine yeah it's gonna look
it's gonna kind of look like a video
game yeah when it's done
so so it's again like it's we're not
we're not trying to like fool people
that there's an actual person that we've
created in virtual space no no no and
it's it's it's very forward forwardly ai
like right there's at no point are is it
ever going to be like
pretending that a person said or wrote
any of this it's all like very that's
but that is the joke which is
this ai is going to come up with these
ai influencers yeah
yeah i know and then but this if it's an
influencer house we get to go to this
other realm now which is like are there
other influencers yeah right
who do they hang out in this home yeah
what else is happening here
you know
he's got the he's got the uh mark jumps
do you see us is there a guy streaming
in like one of the rooms we pass
everyone somewhere like what's happening
here can a skin lord be like hiding in
the basement
creepy easter eggs
it's just even creepier than that this
whole story is a liminal space
influencer
it can it can get very eerie very
quickly yeah like what's that on the
ceiling
what's that dark figure
in the corner of the wall watching us
as she's just dancing like looking
straight into the camera whose head is
clipping through the wall back there and
why are they looking directly in the
camera
[Laughter]
why is it like obviously fun
that's the question i hope this ai can
answer for us we'll design the space of
what's underneath the house but what
happens there right it's not up to us
right the house is built on top of an
old dump where they put all these old
computers yeah they say there are some
souls in those there's some there's some
uh nodes yeah some data some weird ai's
influencers who didn't make it
oh yeah all the past versions yeah it's
like no i know we can get really crazy
and all we do is just say that it exists
we just say there's a haunted graveyard
of past ai influencers
and it does the rest
wow
so i'm excited for that we're filming
that video this week
next week probably
so uh obviously there's
oh no i was just gonna ask like
where are you at like how close are you
sam how close we're we're we're like at
like the v1 stage where it's like lip
sync works basic animation works
wacky and glitchy still nice but like as
i said like the bones are there and we
know what the road map is to completing
this
like uh
probably by the end of the week we'll
have like the basic system running and
then from there it's all about like
you know populating it like getting the
areas fleshed out and stuff
um
yeah i think honestly it's gonna take
probably another like two weeks to like
actually get it done so yeah you know
what's really interesting about that one
is that like a couple years ago i
remember seeing ken levine who is the
guy who did bioshock and stuff he gave a
talk on
basically you remember shadow of mordor
uh the whole side of it where like you
have interactions with characters and
the history of that is played out later
he was just talking about the
ramifications of that for the game
industry and
in an interesting way you guys are kind
of
creating a very primitive version of a
like
of a world that could gen i mean it's in
a game engine like a game that could be
you know procedurally generated like
storytelling essentially exactly well
it's like ai dungeon is
you played that right yeah yeah so it's
like ai dungeon is like the truest
version of that so far
like the biggest thing with those
repetitive stories and having a
procedural it's all about having an
algorithm that actually understands
language and like gpt3 is like basically
the first version of that it's like gpt2
we've messed with that it's
very zany and makes no sense very
frequently whereas gpg3 it's like
it whips itself back in line you know
what i mean like it can do that
so we'll see we'll see where this goes
yeah i mean
it's bottom line is it's a great
creative tool
um and we're trying to put it to good
use and and like do some fun cool stuff
with it and that's that's what we were
doing with the video that's what we're
doing with
these other videos where we're going to
be utilizing it
well idea
i just need to write a blast i just need
to write void room as one of the
locations
and just see what happens when it sets a
post in the void room
obviously there are like ethical and
moral considerations to be uh
vetted um with with the development of
ai with the development of any
technology so
you know um
the more people know
the the better off everyone is about it
honestly um the pioneers were pushing
the freaking limits the more people yeah
the more people know about it and how it
works and how it doesn't work and we'll
do our part to like
give information like this if we see if
we put out a video and it's like oh
clearly there was context missing we'll
do we'll do stuff like this to
put more context to it and like
not trying to brush off all the comments
we hear the concern
it's noted and yeah i mean i think next
time there's something related to
consent maybe we'll use better verbiage
and a bit more tact and how we approach
that and maybe have a slightly more
positive spin at the end yeah yeah i
think that's a big thing it's like it
needs the it needs the post credit scene
where it's like yeah ah that was a real
good one yeah same time next week all
right
that's like it's the same thing with the
peter thing it's the same thing with
this video people it's our it's our own
fault because we've made you guys into
lovable characters and the audience
has a connection to you so when they see
one of you done dirty
bad it's bad all bad right so my senpai
exactly and that's something we can
that's the biggest takeaway i've i've
gotten from those two videos
so are you pressing charges should i
call 911 right now yeah actually sam
i've seen a fraud if you want to go
to queensland australia oh yeah the laws
are a little different there yeah i've
got tickets already you guys could
really bond over that i think yeah oh
let's do it okay okay like deep into the
bush where no one's going to know
someone comes back yeah yeah
what do they hunt with other over there
well i think
i mean they took away people's safety
it was like
thing i think right yeah
yeah
would be fine yeah sounds good they just
throw venomous spiders on the animal
this one's got some good venom
[Laughter]
all right oh man
well that was a good one all right i
i've always i'm always excited because
each week you never know we always have
like you know here's our plan for this
week but then things happen and it's
it's always fun to just be able to jump
on it and talk about it sometimes you
get pranked sometimes you get pranked
around here you never know yep well
still you're surprised people aren't as
offended about
[Laughter]
yeah we had to stop doing it because he
ran into a wall yeah but that's a good
example of when we he said stop and then
we stopped right so right guys
to be clear he was okay with us putting
out those videos yeah but he was like
can you also not do that again yeah as
long as the spiders are like in a d and
d setting he handles it yeah yeah
there's a lot of those things anyways
all right then until next time thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
watching being reasonable consider
subscribing subscribe